hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new and aspiring software engineers
and today
is going to be super fun because i am
answering your
questions if you follow me on instagram
you knew you could ask me questions
there
which i would feature on my qa video if
you don't follow me on instagram at the
black female engineer
but let's get to it i'm going to be
reading the questions off my laptop and
so if you all see me
looking over here that is why but we're
going to start off with
ronica alexandia who asks how many
hours did you dedicate to learning to
code and so i primarily learned to code
through coding boot camp during my time
there
i spent about 10 hours a day
the boot camp ran from 9 00 a.m to 5 p.m
every day so already that's eight hours
and then i'll spend another like
four hours um still learning still
developing still practicing
however i would make sure to um like
step away and eat um so let's say that's
you know two hours
for doing that and so it does round it
back to 10 hours a day of yeah just
making sure that i was understanding and
picking up what the teachers were
talking about because it's so easy to
while you're in
the class to be like oh yeah yeah yeah
like
that makes total sense and then you get
to
doing it by yourself and you're like how
in the world
did two and two make four in this
situation how
so i really focus on
practicing um to do that but to answer
your question it was about
10 hours a day going to the next
question we have
at eat now dot think later i like that
they ask if you could redo your time at
flatiron
what would you do differently i survived
week one oh my goodness congratulations
each week is a reason to celebrate like
y'all this ain't
it ain't no joke i think if i could have
had certain stopping points of okay from
five to six we eat dinner and just watch
tv
and don't talk to anyone and then we
make sure we close the laptop at eight
o'clock
don't open it back up until you know the
next morning make sure you had two hour
breaks here
i feel like i still would have gotten
the same hours of practicing
without it being as emotionally
strenuous
i personally did experience burnout and
i um
like my mental state definitely took
their hits because
i wasn't making myself stop
because i was just so engulfed with the
idea of i
will make sure i end this with a job a
good pay job
and you know all of my efforts off the
money going in here will not you know
be go to waste however there are
definitely right and wrong ways to
go about that goal and i don't think
mine was always the best
way i feel like if i did you know enact
certain rules for myself to just make
sure
that my mental well-being was being of
top priority
i feel like i still could have done that
in a way that still wouldn't give me
the same if not better results that i
got
um i love the results i got i got a job
but i'm just saying
i don't think like me doing it the way i
did is the only
way i would have gotten to where i ended
to
but yeah making sure i enact a certain
rules for
learning and breaks and stops for myself
next question comes from benjamin832
and they asked can you do a review on
nou camp
since the curriculum seems good and it's
very
inexpensive at eighteen hundred dollars
um benjamin are you asking me to do a
whole another boot camp is that what you
ask
and pay eighteen hundred dollars for it
is that what you're asking
um if that's what you're asking me to do
i am so sorry i will not
i will i will not put myself through
that
again um especially if i'm the one
paying are you paying
the 800 the 18 hundred dollars or am i
paying the eighteen
hundred dollars um let me know if that's
what you mean i
could however um try to do some research
on it and let you know
what the consensus seems to be if that's
what you mean
i could look into that and i could like
try to see um what the goods and bads
are that
the community says not that i say
because again
i'm not going through any of that again
but yeah let me know if that's what you
mean
because that's a very uh important
detail right there okay so
next question comes from at paa.willy20
and they ask which company are you
working with
so i work for an e-commerce company
they specialize in creating websites and
web apps
for companies in the e-commerce
industry and so that's actually why i've
been so busy right now
i am under two different contracts at
the moment
one is phasing out and one right now the
e-commerce company
is phasing in and so i just started
there have been
training and everything and so i just
started there about a couple weeks ago
and then i have a couple weeks left of
contract one
and so i'm in this overlap period where
i'm working
a lot a lot a lot working a lot so if
you see me tired and everything that is
why i'm hoping to be a lot more active
on social media and everything in a
couple of weeks
when job one phases out so yeah that's
the type of company i
work with it's actually different from
the company you all will hear me talking
about
in terms of the job i got after boot
camp and
you know salaries and things like that
because that job is set to start in the
summer so in the meantime i've been
doing temporary development work for
different companies under different
you know contracts and everything so i'm
very much looking forward to that but
yeah until
i start that permanent role i'm choosing
to keep that
um under wraps just you know like
fingers crossed knock on wood
i don't have any wood knock on wood but
yeah okay so the next question comes
from comp sci
dixon who asks favorite programming
language
my favorite programming language um i
guess programming framework
is react i love love love
react people who have um damned me and
talked
um with me about their coding journey
and everything know i love
react it just like flows really nicely
now that being said it took me forever
to actually start liking it i just
didn't understand it for the
life of me for a very long time until i
just started
just practicing like crazy and it
finally started clicking
and i just really like the way react
flows where javascript
things are just kind of like has to go
where they go and you just hope things
work react has a very beautiful flow to
it
and i just love it so yeah that's my
favorite programming language so next
atkincama asks how long did you prepare
yourself for your bootcamp
and while in it how did you take note
i prepared for specifically bootcamp i
prepared about a month
i would make sure i would be doing you
know courses on codecademy like
javascript
i would make sure that i was also going
through their
own pre-bootcamp material extensively
they provided us with about a hundred
hours of pre-boot camp material
so yeah i went through that like crazy
just making sure
that day one i can really kick it off um
well because
something with boot camp is like once
you're behind you kind of like
stay behind it's kind of like the
mindset people have and they're not
necessarily
wrong now of course if you're behind one
day of course like there's ways you can
catch up
but yeah once you get to a certain point
of being behind
it's very hard to catch back up and so i
was gonna make
sure that i was like starting ahead
if anything and then i think there's a
second question oh while
in it how did you take note i didn't
really take notes some people took
notes um i learned by doing and so what
i would do
is while while the teacher
was going through the material i'd be
coding along the
it wasn't it was rarely ever a class
where
the teacher is just like writing on like
a border or like you know
just saying things it would most of the
time like 90 of the time
the lessons would be coding something
out and learning while coding and so i
would code along that is how i learned
best
and then after that i would re-watch the
lecture
two three times to really get that
practicing
make sure i understood before i moved on
so that's yeah yeah that's really how i
went through those lessons
next question comes from at new nesta
who asks what's your favorite animal
my favorite animal by far is an elephant
i love elephants
i am a very sensitive person like so so
i'm so sensitive y'all um and so
i love elephants because they feel
emotions very deeply
and they are very family oriented and i
was actually
born in zimbabwe and so i've gotten to
go back and i've gone to
ride an elephant and that was just the
most amazing time
ever like i just wanted to cry the
entire time just so amazing
so yeah i really love elephants i
appreciate that more lighthearted
question
at modestly underscore magnificent
asks how are you liking your job did you
contemplate
engineering when you were a finance
major
so so far i like this new job
the people are super chill i think like
the mindset is more like startup mindset
they're not really a startup they have
multiple locations
but i feel like that's more the mindset
it's very chill it's very like
do your job and you know come again
tomorrow
like it's really um fun and chill and
yeah the people have been really great
in like aiding in that that training and
that learning
so i really appreciate that and did you
contemplate engineering when you were a
finance major
i didn't okay so here's the thing here's
the thing
fun fact before i um was a major
in finance i was a double major in
finance and accounting
before i got into that business school i
actually enrolled into my college as a
computer science major
and that's something that's like really
funny to think about it wasn't really
because i wanted to learn to code it was
just like when i looked at the different
career paths that all these different
majors and all these different
you know schools and colleges provided
just engineering seemed like the thing
that would afford me the life
i wanted to see for myself both like day
to day
and in terms of like financially and you
know
allowing me to hit certain goals for
myself and things like that
but it had really nothing to do with the
coding it was just like okay i guess you
know
this wouldn't be a bad life to have but
then like a couple weeks later i got a
letter
that i was accepted into the business
school and so i just automatically
switched over because that was actually
the thing i had
wanted really badly and so yeah i had
never
contemplated it so no it's funny how
things come full
circle with yeah starting off maybe not
starting off but signing on
as a computer science student and then
four months six months after my
graduation
being hired as a software engineer so
that's it's very funny next question
comes from curly shawnee who asks does
it matter whether you work
at a tech startup or a large company as
a first time software
engineering job after boot camp
no i don't think it matters at all to be
completely honest i honestly don't think
either
is like bad or like good
what you have to consider however is
which
you would be happier with because
there's pros and cons
with both and i do plan on making a
separate video on this in the future so
i won't go
too deep into it but basically startups
as you know a developer at a startup
you can expect to wear different hats
now that's something that
some people may love and may keep some
people saying because
you're not doing the same thing over and
over and over again because with a big
company
odds are for every little thing that you
know
that company deals with there's a person
for that job
i like someone's that at um twitter or
at google there is a team a whole huge
team
just for the comments like feature of
like
google docs and so imagine you know
being a developer on that team and
spending a year
just working on the comment box feature
of google
some people that would just drive them
insane but then
others you know they like the stability
and they like knowing what their
day-to-day
will look like so i really don't think
it matters which one you choose
what it'll come down to or what it
should come down to
is which is best for your personality
type
and what um you like to see day to day
now going to part two of the question do
you think
software engineering is stressful if so
why
yeah i
definitely think software engineering is
stressful
and for me it's more because of
how nitty-gritty it can feel you have to
be so
so detailed in your coding and that's
something that i see can get me and
other people into trouble
is skipping those steps of saying to the
computer
reach here look here do this do that
that's what gets people into trouble
that's kind of what
has in my past has created errors for me
and things like that because i'm not
being extremely like
in my process now that's something that
we of course
learn i have definitely learned from my
mistakes and i have definitely
done better but i do find it stressful
when you think you are acting
in that manner of making sure you are
really
coding out things step by step and yet
your computer is like nah son like
i can't find the peanut butter like you
said it was in column three where
where's column three like it makes
things difficult and so it can make
things very stressful
but also it can be very very rewarding
when
you can finally say at the end of the
day this is the thing i have with my
blood sweat and tears with my everything
i've been pouring out
here is my baby but yeah software
engineering is trustful but it's also
very
rewarding so part three of the question
is also how do you remember everything
when learning
how to code i
learn out of habits i think
that has really been the best way i
learned by not trying to memorize things
i think it's better to learn how
a process works and know
why this process comes after this
process in x y and z
because i find that with memorizing
things that's where you can get into
trouble because now you're not actually
understanding you're just
memorizing and the thing about
memorization especially with code is
it'll work for that one app you're
building but once you
switch over to a new team it's not going
to work because it's different functions
and different
inputs in x y and z and so it's more
important to know
the why behind things because now when
you switch over to the team
you know that oh i know that when we
want to do this we use this
because the database works like x y and
z
and so the only way i get to do that is
by practicing and then
really seeing how the pieces fit
together
that's at the end of day was going to
carry us further
rather than simply memorizing so last
question at salsa underscore snob asks
what do you enjoy the most about
development and what do you enjoy the
least
the thing i enjoyed the most of
development would have to be
that amazing feeling you get when
something works
when um yeah you like type up a line of
code and then
refresh your page and like you see that
element pop up or that design look
correct and work correct
you just want to just scream in like
excitement
and just join it just makes like my
whole day
now what i enjoyed the least is the flip
side of that
the not working part and
specifically how precise things need to
be
where you you can spend an hour or more
going in circles not knowing why your
code
isn't working and then you look back and
see that there's a comma where it's not
supposed to be and then boom
your whole app is there there you go and
you spent
hours on this that makes me just like so
furious and so mad like i can
feel just like the fury running through
my veins i just hate it so
much but um but yeah at the end of the
day it's all worth it
getting to see that final product and
being able to say like you know what
i made that you see that i did that
so yeah that's something i very much
appreciate and enjoy
thank you so much everyone for all of
your questions if you're watching this
and
some questions pop up for you please do
not hesitate to dm me at the black
female engineer or comment below
and yeah let's get that conversation
going i love answering those questions
for you guys
but yeah this is super fun i hope you
enjoyed it too
and i will see y'all later bye y'all